it has been almost a little over a year
since first came out on youtube i know
it's been challenging at times
but so rewarding what has been the most
special part of this journey for you i
am
so incredibly proud of this documentary
it really changed my life
it was so healing just to finally
let so many things go and and talk about
things i never spoke about before
and i'm just really proud of
my film and the effect it's had on
people and just all the love and support
that i've received since i've
released it last year i know it's made a
difference too but it's also made a
difference to a lot of other people who
spoke in front of senate
where are we at with that and how
important for you is that
to share your story and to really
pioneer a change
it really shows that the truth will set
you free and it's powerful and i really
turned
my pain into a purpose and speaking of
the senate and
passing my first law so that everything
that happened to myself and so many
others
would now be illegal today and now i'm
going to be taking it to a federal level
so in all 50 states this will not be
available to happen to children anymore
so it's so rewarding that that happened
because i just know the little girl and
me
back then would be so proud of the woman
that i am today absolutely and we were
speaking to alex and she said
she knows you and carter are the real
deal because that's the side he sees of
you
he's there standing beside you and
you're fighting this fight together how
much does your support mean during this
to have a man like that at your side
i've seized that partner
you're gonna make me cry and ask him the
question like that he's
i've never met a man like this in my
life i've never been with someone who
loves and supports me so much and lifts
me up
and isn't intimidated and is just
like my best friend and my prince
charming
all rolled into one and always by my
side
every time we went to anywhere that has
to do with what i'm doing for my
activism
he's always by my side and i'm just so
blessed and i can't wait for the next
step in our life
we can't wait for your wedding yes where
are we at with that i know we spoke to
recently but um would we have a dress do
we have a date
well we just started shooting our new
show paris and love on peacock
and uh we're shooting in new york just
now actually
and uh getting ready for the dress
fitting and just
planning the bachelorette party and
there's a lot so i'm
i'm really excited to share that with
all my fans does this mean the wedding
and televised
yes i didn't know that we knew that yes
that was huge
mom was actually just with us you know
and she's amazing she would be happy
with hot dogs and hamburgers and petting
zoo
at your wedding is that true is this
going to be casual parents
um i don't think that's the wedding buy
for me but
definitely something magical and fun and
you know i'm not your traditional bread
and there's gotta be animals i mean
there's gonna be piglets or something
there has to be like my little
chihuahua diamond baby what do you make
of your mom as like the breakout star
of housewife's family house my mom is so
hilarious and so much fun and that's
really where i get most of my sense of
humor from
just that's how she is she's a character
and
i love watching her on the show she's so
[Music]
funny
you